quand même debout
ce paysagiste a pris la déposer ses
déchets verts sur cette plateforme de
compostage
créé il ya deux ans en pleine bourre
avant c'était déchetterie principalement
donc c'est vraiment un atout un atout de
proximité car les cinq à six mille
tonnes de déchets récupérés ici chaque
année proviennent d'un rayon de 30 km de
ce côté là on va retrouver tout ce qui
est gazon et bois broyé et enfin toute
la partie fumier collègues dont
principalement dans les centres
équestres un atout écologique aussi car
paul hôpitaux et son père transforme
cette matière en compost 100% bio pour
ce faire ils interdisent les boues de
stations d'épuration et suivre un cahier
des charges précis pour éliminer tout
germe et résidus chimiques ici en
agriculture banques on composte agréé
bio on est obligés d'avoir une montée en
température à plus de 70 degrés et se
passait alors ses plusieurs fois ces
trois fois et se passer d'une semaine
alors qu'on a quand on compose
conventionnelle on est uniquement à 150
degrés
après neuf mois de travail le compost
est vendu environ 16 euros la tonne à
une cinquantaine de paysagistes
agriculteurs bio mais aussi
conventionnel en eure et loir
l'agriculteur conventionnelle
aujourd'hui regardent de plus en plus
cette tendance compost pour plusieurs
raisons effectivement l'engrais chimique
est peut être un peu moins cher dans
certains cas le marché du chimique
fluctuent énormément le compost on est
beaucoup plus stable mais il faut savoir
que le compost apporter un tas de mad
d'éléments nutritifs supplémentaire que
n'apporte pas le simple engrais
chimiques qui lui donne à manger qu'à la
plante
si paul hôpitaux utilisent son compost
pour redynamiser le sol de ses propres
champs il en a fine désormais une petite
partie pour le vendre aux particuliers
une version améliorée qui l'appelle de
l'or noir